since 2001 The Fast and Furious movies
have morphed into a massive sprawling
franchise in fact the series easily
Rivals most comic book movies for
surprisingly dense lore outrageous
action and heroic one might even say
super heroic leads in 2001's the Fast
and the Furious were introduced to Brian
O'Connor an undercover cop tasked with
taking down a gang of muscle car loving
thieves who have been stealing what they
claim to be millions of dollars of DVD
players Brian finds a lead in Dominic
Toretto the charismatic ringleader of a
group of car heads who may or may not be
the same gang that Brian's after I live
my life a quarter mile at a time
to make things even more complicated
dumb sister Mia the shop owner of
toretto's Market is the object of
Brian's affection Brian impressed as
dumb with his driving eventually
ingratiating himself into Dom's team
which isn't a family just yet
unfortunately Brian soon learns that he
can only play both sides of the law for
so long and comes clean to the Toretto
family when it looks like Dominus gang
will end up on the wrong end of a
trucker shotgun with Brian's cover blown
and dumb Force to leave town the two
have won last quarter mile race
ultimately rather than take his new
friend into custody Brian gives Dom the
keys to his car and lets him race off
into the distance Too Fast Too Furious
surprisingly isn't the second part of
this franchise instead that honor goes
to the turbocharged prelude for 2 Fast 2
Furious a short film which sees Brian on
the run after letting Dom Go free for
some reason this leads to a nationwide
manhunt with his face plastered all over
the Nightly News that sort of thing
tends to present a problem when you're
driving across America winning street
races like some sort of gear shaft
version of Johnny Appleseed when cops
sees his vehicle while Brian's driving
through Texas is able to head to ride
with an unnamed woman who recognizes his
face possibly because of his uncanny
resemblance to Lance Harbor from Varsity
Blues after that he buys a new car wins
more street races and finds himself in
Miami the city where the heat is on In
2003's Too Fast Too Furious Brian has
fully transformed from undercover cop
with an unmistakable Surfer accent into
a king of the Miami Street Racing scene
with an unmistakable Surfer accent
together with organizer and former racer
tej Brian's been racking up the bills
and notoriety in Miami that all comes to
a screeching halt when he's arrested by
the Miami police after they fire an
electronic Harpoon into his car the
police want Brian to go undercover
inside a criminal organization and
they're willing to wipe Brian's criminal
record if he can take down Varone
Miami's resident drug lord Brian
recruits his childhood best friend and
ex-con Roman to help him raise his way
to veron's good greatest with the help
of another undercover agent Monica
Fuentes Brian and Roman capture verone
clear their criminal records and walk
away with a pile of illicitly acquired
kirsh and that's about when the timeline
hits turbo speed with chronological
hijinks Los Bandoleros was a short film
co-written and directed by Vin Diesel
that serves as a Prelude to the fourth
film Fast and Furious following damasi
assembles a new crew For an upcoming
Heist of a gasoline truck in the
Dominican Republic let his back to
rekindle her romance with dom but she's
not the only familiar face in the short
film Han originally appeared and died
three years earlier in the Fast and the
Furious Tokyo Drift which was the third
movie released a quick line of dialogue
establishes that the Han we see here has
never been to Japan so we know that this
takes place before Tokyo Drift But now
though all you need to know is that Dom
loves Letty the people of the Dominican
Republic and stealing gas from the ridge
to give to the poor 2009's Fast and
Furious begins at the heist planned in
the Los Bandolero shot domleti Han Tego
and Santos steal a bunch of gas to give
to the people of the Dominican Republic
but their celebration is short-lived Dom
knows that as long as he's a wanted
criminal lettuce in danger of being
arrested too so he leaves Letty in the
middle of the night after go live his
life one quarter mile at a time
meanwhile Brian is working with the FBI
to feel agent trying to find leads on a
drug lord named Braga Dom is forced to
return to Los Angeles after learning
that Letty was seemingly killed by one
of braga's men while she was working
with Brian to take the drug lord down in
exchange for clearing Dom's criminal
record Dom and Brian both go undercover
and Braga Street Racing Organization
Brian intending to catch bragger Dom
intending to kill him while there they
run into him befriend Giselle braga's
wondrous right-hand woman eventually
dumb and Brian reconcile and take Braga
down
I would have won that race if you didn't
cheat right
you let your head off
unfortunately Dom is captured by the FBI
and sentenced to 25 years in prison for
all of his Prior Street Racing related
crimes luckily for him Brian is used to
going against the law to save his friend
the film ends with Brian Mia and the
rest of the crew teaming up to break Dom
out 2011's Fast 5 picks up immediately
where Fast and Furious left off Dom
escaped from prison with his family and
the crew heads to Rio De Janeiro to
figure out their next moves Brian takes
a gig stealing cars from a train but
unbeknownst to the family one of the
cars they steal belongs to Reyes a
ruthless drug lord who controls Rio with
an iron fist Don mere and Brian
recognize that they've got a golden
opportunity to steal enough money from
Reyes to fund their fugitive lives
permanently it's more than a
three-person job so they put out the
call for the whole family to assemble
Roman Ted Giselle Han tago and Santos
all arrive ready to steal 100 million
from Reyes unfortunately Reyes isn't the
only obstacle in their way Luke Hobbs a
Diplomatic Security Service agent and
all-around tough guy is on the hunt for
the family along for the ride is a a Rio
patrol officer with a grudge against
Rayos for the murder of her husband
Darwin Hobbes have their requisite tough
guy Face-Off
this is Brazil
but they're forced to work together
after Reyes kills hobb's entire team say
for himself and Elena the family's Heist
goes off without a hitch and Hobbs gives
Dom a full 24-hour grace period before
they resumed their muscular cat and
muscular Mouse chase at the end of Fast
Five there were only two things that
could get the family back in action the
promise of amnesty and the knowledge
that Letty is alive it turns out that
Letty survived the explosion back in
Fast and Furious but got amnesia she was
then conscripted into a kind of evil
version of The Fast family led by
villainous Owen Shaw Hobbs and his new
partner Riley bring the fast family
because obviously only fast thieves can
catch fast thieves
it wasn't that hard to find you Toretto
wasn't hiding eventually through the
magic of Street Racing Dom's able to
convince Letty that she's being
manipulated by Shore and convinces her
to join the team unfortunately she's not
the only double agent Riley's been
working for sure the whole time just
waiting for the perfect opportunity to
betray halves it all comes to a head on
the world's longest airstrip as a fast
family's battle to stop Shore from
escaping the secret government
technology Giselle sacrifices herself to
save Han sure is stopped and ultimately
the family's previous crimes are
forgiven allowing them to return to Los
Angeles once again after giselle's death
in 2013's Fast and Furious 6 Han finally
makes good on his promise to visit Tokyo
in a movie released seven years earlier
the Fast and the Furious Tokyo Drift the
third movie released in the series Tokyo
Drift was a failed effort to reinvent
the franchise without Paul Walker or Vin
Diesel and most of the film concerns
itself with Sean Boswell he's a high
school scholar sent to live with his
family in Tokyo after his penchant for
street racing land him in hot water in
the states Sean meets Han who's call us
ice Persona and street racing skills
have made him a major player in the
underground racing scene Han takes Sean
under his wing even loaning him a car
and tutoring him in the ways of drifting
to beat DK the nephew of a Yakuza Crime
Boss
you know what DK stands for
Donkey Kong
drift King
unfortunately Hans trading is
interrupted when DK and his uncle's
henchmen attack Hans Garage in the
ensuing chase scene Han Is tragically
hit by a passing motorist and his fuel
tank goes up in a massive ball of fire
consumed with raging Vengeance Shawn
challenges DK to a race in which the
winner has to leave town forever Sean
wins becoming the new drift King and Dom
shows up explaining that harm was family
the post-credits scene of Fast and
Furious 6 returned to Han's death in
Tokyo Drift But with one major bit of
contacts a mysterious stranger who's
following the chase on a police scanner
with careful timing The Stranger speeds
right into Han and then that has yet
named character calls Dom on the phone
as Hans car Burns delivering a
foreboding message
Dominic to real
you don't know me
you're about to there's nothing more
important than family in the Fast and
Furious universe but bad guys are
families too in this case Owen sure is a
big brother named Deckard he kills Han
in the post-credits scene of Fast and
Furious 6. when the family hears about
Han's death Dom travels to Tokyo to pay
his respects and start the hunt for
Deckard meanwhile Decker's been busy
he's already attacked Hobbes and Elena
to find out everything he can about the
fast family when Dom finally meets
Deckard their climactic street fighters
interrupted by mysterious government
agent named Mr Nobody who needs a dumb
and his team to do some odd jobs for
them in return for the use of God's eye
a hacking tool that can find anyone on
the planet including Deckard
this time it ain't just about being fast
team rescues Ramsay the hacker who
designed God's eye from a Somali
mercenary trying to use the device for
nefarious reasons it all comes to a head
in Los Angeles of course where Dom and
his team need to keep Ramsay away from
Deckard long enough for her to disable
the God's eye fortunately they have some
help from Hobbs
Deckard Shaw has taken to jail after Don
beats him by stomping on a parking
garage like the Incredible Hulk and then
Dom briefly dies and is resurrected with
the Power of Love thus avenging Han the
real-life death of Paul Walker Lisa the
character Brian's retirement as he rides
off into the sunset with Mia and their
son
after going to Havana and winning a
street race by driving backwards in a
car that literally explodes dumb runs
into Cipher a cyber terrorist who
blackmails him into betraying his family
for the only reason he would even more
family Dom's ex-girlfriend Elena
secretly had his child between the
events of Fast and Furious 6 and fate of
the Furious and Cipher is holding the
two of them hostage unless Dom gives her
what she wants nuclear weapons when Don
battles against his family and Mr Nobody
he calls in favors from some old friends
and recent enemies including the shore
brothers who now have full-on jet bugs
they will help Dom double cross Cipher
but unfortunately Elena dies and Cipher
escapes to lick her wounds and plot a
future sequel that could sure arrive to
the requisite post battle meal with
Dom's son who's named Brian after dumb's
best friend what's next for the family
coming in August of 2019 is Fast and
Furious presents Hobbs and Shore which
will see the eponymous Odd Couple facing
off against a super-powered Idris Elba
look at me
I'm black Superman Fast and Furious 9 is
slated for 2020 and while there hasn't
been much news about it since an
animated show called Fast and Furious
spy Racers was announced in April 2018.
now with reports of onset conflicts
between series leads the future looks
cloudy the spin-off might be a way to
keep Dwayne The Rock Johnson and his
popular character in the universe
without him sharing screen time with Vin
Diesel whatever else is on the road
ahead no one really knows for sure all
we can do is get there ourselves one
quarter mile at a time
today Dominic Toretto is one of
Hollywood's most beloved action heroes a
StreetWise American family man whose
uncanny abilities behind the wheel have
elevated him from truck robbing Street
racer to globetrotting world saving
Adventure even still like most Heroes
he's had his fair share of mistakes
along the way
as a boy growing up in Los Angeles
Dominic Toretto idolizes his father a
local stock car racer Dom's father
models many of the values that our hero
comes to represent later in life he
loves cars and driving he's a man of
faith and a community leader and nothing
is more important to him than his family
so when Dom Witnesses his father's death
on the racetrack he is absolutely
devastated Dom's father is killed in an
accident caused by a fellow racer named
Kenny Linder who Clips the Alder
toretto's bumper and sends him crashing
into a wall at Terminal speeds Dom runs
into Linder the week after the accident
and enraged by what he feels was a
preventable accident attacks Linda with
wrench Dom only plans on hitting him
once but then loses control of himself
and leaves Linder seriously injured Dom
not only ends lender's racing career but
he leaves him physically unable to drive
for years to come Dom is sentenced to
two years in prison for the assault and
he's banned from professional Racing for
Life Dom's assaulted Kenny Lander is the
inciting incident that sets the entire
fast Saga into motion Dominic's redo may
have had a career as a legitimate stock
car racer and wouldn't have had to turn
to street racing to satisfy his Need for
Speed or steal Electronics to finance
his sister's education
early in his criminal career Dom has a
business arrangement with Johnny Tran a
fellow thief and Street racer Johnny is
a dangerous man with a vicious streak
dumb would be wise to stay on his good
side but he risks their business
relationship when he sleeps with
Johnny's sister in an apparently casual
fling Johnny takes offense to this and
he and Dom part carving up their
territory and agreeing to stay out of
each other's way time for you to go do
your own thing but in the fast and the
furious Dom accidentally violates that
truce when he and Brian O'Connor ride
through Johnny's Turf reigniting their
rivalry Brian doesn't help matters
either as he suspects Johnny of
coordinating a string of truck robberies
and arranges a police raid of his home
humiliating him in front of his family
Johnny mistakenly believes that Dom is
the one who ratted him out and he
confronts him at the race Wars
competition in front of their peers on
the racing scene to make matters worse
Dom's friend Jesse challenges Johnny to
erase and loses then flees out of panic
rather than handing over his pink slip
as agreed Johnny retaliates with the
drive-bye shooting of the Toretto family
home in which Jesse is killed forcing
Brian to return fire and kill Johnny Dom
isn't solely to blame for all this but
had he not put his libido ahead of his
business the Bloodshed between the Tran
and Toretto Cruise might have been
avoided
in the fast and the furious Dom makes
one major fateful mistake that
profoundly reshapes the rest of his life
when he welcomes a relative stranger
Street racer and mechanic Brian Earl
spillner into his inner circle Dom is
initially suspicious and dismissive of
Brian who in addition to poking his head
into Dom's domain as a street racer also
frequents the Toretto family grocery to
flirt with Tom's sister Mia but after
Brian helps Dom avoid arrests for street
racing Tom begins to warm up to this guy
and gradually lets him into his life and
closer to his criminal Enterprise
unbeknownst to Dom Brian spillner is
actually Brian O'Connor an undercover
LAPD officer assigned to investigate a
series of truck robberies for which Dom
and his crew are responsible Dom ignores
the signs of Brian's true agenda and
even the warnings of his close friend
Vince until it's too late and Dom's
operation is exposed Brian allows Dom to
escape from the police but Dom is still
forced to leave the country and embark
on a series of increasingly daring
heists to make a living until his
eventual pardon in Fast and Furious 6.
while trusting Brian O'Connor is
certainly a mistake in the moment
eventually Brian and Dom reconcile and
come to see each other as brothers Brian
and Mia's relationship also stands the
test of time and Don becomes the proud
Uncle to their two children
the original Fast and the Furious
introduces a large-scale racing event
and car show held in the desert outside
of Los Angeles where Street Racers can
compete for Glory cash and pink slips
without interference from the police
it's a serious well-organized Enterprise
complete with DJ's dancers and a
security staff in Furious 7 Dom reveals
that he and Letty Ortiz invented the
ritual which means that Dom and Letty
may also be responsible for its very
unfortunate name race Wars Dom and Letty
would have been pretty young when they
came up with this name and likely didn't
give much thought to the other
connotations of the phrase race war but
now we all have to live with it and we
don't just mean in the movies the race
wars in the Fast and the Furious has
inspired similar regularly recurring
events around the world including in the
United States Germany and Australia the
idea of creating a space where Street
Racers can show off their skills and
their machines in style and in relative
safety is a novel one the problem is
that these real life events also borrow
their name from The Fast and Furious
films going with the similar but legally
distinct one word title of race Wars
thanks for that one Tom
in Fast and Furious and its prequel
short film Los Bandoleros Dom is
revealed to be on the run from
authorities and living in the Dominican
Republic where he and his new crew plan
to steal a tanker of gasoline on the eve
of the heist Dom's girlfriend from Los
Angeles Letty Ortiz arrives in town
looking for him the couple rekindles
their relationship and as revealed in
Furious 7 are married in a private
ceremony The Heist is a success but law
enforcement is catching up to them Dom
fears that his capture may be inevitable
so he slips away while Letty is asleep
hoping that leaving her behind might
save her from going down with him this
turns out to be a grave error still
hoping for her happy ending Letty
returns to the United States and offers
to work undercover for the FBI in
exchange for a pardon for dumb so that
the two of them can both go home when
ladies cover is blown she's seriously
wounded and presumed killed now in
amnesiac Letty then joins up with the
mercenary crew led by Owen Shaw and goes
head to head against stom and his team
while she ultimately joins Dom's family
late in Fast and Furious 6 but he
doesn't regain her memories until the
end of furious 7. had Dom respected
lety's choice to share the risk of their
Outlaw lifestyle both of them could have
been spared a lot of Heartache in fast
and furious Dom goes hunting for
arturobraga the international drug
dealer he believes is responsible for
letty's death in order to get close to
Braga Dom auditions to join the fleet of
performance drivers that Braga uses to
smuggle his product across the Mexican
U.S border once he's admitted into their
ranks Dawn begins working closely with a
man calling himself Ramon Campos who
claims to be an associate of bragas this
turns out to be a ruse as Campos is
actually Braga himself working under an
assumed identity in order to keep the
upper hand in situations like this one
to throw people off his scent Braga
employs a decoy to portray him in public
this Ploy works just long enough for
Braga to escape the Trap set for him by
Dom Brian and the FBI allowing him to
escape to Mexico just as in the fast and
the furious Dom spends most of this film
missing something that's right under his
nose Dom and Brian capture Braga in
Mexico soon after but Braga should be
grateful that Dom didn't determine his
true identity earlier if Dom had known
who he was when they first met he
probably would have killed killed him on
the spot in Fast Five Dom Brian and Mia
find themselves in Rio de Janeiro where
their old friend Vince offers them each
a spot on a team that plans to hijack
three performance cars from aboard a
moving train Vince says that the goal of
the heist is to sell the cars quickly
for cash on the black market but he
hides their true secret objective Vince
also chooses not to reveal that the cars
they're stealing have been repossessed
by the United States drug enforcement
agency and that there will be armed DEA
agents on the train when the heist
begins Dom quickly senses that the other
members of their crew have information
that he Brian and Mia do not he calls an
audible telling Mia to take the car that
seems most important and hide it away
rather than drive it to the agreed upon
Rendezvous Point change the plans wait
for my call this car turns out to be the
real Target of the heist as it contains
a computer chip belonging to local drug
Baron Hernan Reyes the mission soon
barrels out of control and three of
reyes's men and three DEA agents are
guilt this puts Dom Brian and Mia in the
crosshairs of both Reyes and the US
government as usual the toretos find a
way to turn the situation to their
advantage even still the entire mess
including six fatalities might have been
avoided if Dom had just allowed the
heists to play out as planned
in Fast and Furious 6 Dom gets the news
that the love of his life Letty Ortiz is
still alive and a member of Owen Shaw's
hardened mercenary crew at the behest of
DSs agent Luke Hobbs Dom assembles his
team in the hopes of reuniting with
Letty and bringing her home as well as
stopping Shaw from assembling the
components of a dangerous
electromagnetic weapon when Dom catches
up to Letty in the aftermath of a
high-speed chase in London he approaches
her with his guard down unbeknownst to
Dom Letty has no memory of Dom or their
life together and she shoots them in the
shoulder seemingly without a thought
Dom's mistake here is understandable as
it would have been difficult for him to
predict that someone he's known since
childhood and is secretly married to
would have completely forgotten him but
any error that results in getting shot
is still a pretty big deal also
according to Letty herself it could have
been a lot worse Letty later claims that
her aim was off and that she'd plan to
shoot to kill Tom disputes this but
assuming she is telling the truth Dom's
mistake might well have cost him his
life thank only this incident doesn't
discourage Dom from reaching out to
Letty and his implicit trust in her is
part of what convinces Letty to switch
sides and help to take Sean down
Furious 7 pits Dom against Deckard Shaw
who's out for Revenge after the defeat
of his brother Owen the villain proves
he means business by killing Dom's
friend Han and destroying the toretto's
beloved family home next Shaw stalks the
crew at Han's funeral and Dom makes the
questionable decision of chasing after
him alone rather than taking the rest of
the crew with him the standoff ends with
the two of them in their cars playing
chicken and neither of them blink Dom
chargesha head on with his Plymouth
Roadrunner unaware that Shaw has heavily
reinforced the chassis of his Maserati
Ghibli Dom steps out of his wrecked
Plymouth as the more injured of the two
men and durrage shot for what he sees as
an underhanded tactic the Dom hasn't
caught on that he's no longer living in
the world of Street Racing or even
street level crime he's in Shaw's world
now a world of Espionage in which Dom
can't expect a sense of fair play if not
for the timely arrival of Mr Nobody and
his Strike Force Shaw would have shocked
Dom dead right then and there by the end
of Furious 7 Dom has learned his lesson
when Dom and John play chicken again in
the film's climax Dom pulls a wheelie
and jumps the front of his signature
charger over the top of Sean's Aston
Martin giving him the upper hand in
their final street fight
in the fate of the furious Dom is
extorted into doing the bidding of
international cyber terrorist Cipher who
hopes to use the skills to help spark a
nuclear war Cipher lures Dom into her
employ by capturing his ex-girlfriend
Elena Nieves along with Marcos the
infant's son Dom didn't know he had with
the two of them held hostage Cipher has
total leverage over Dom which she uses
to compel him to betray his family steal
nuclear launch codes and help hijack a
Russian submarine as awful as this
situation is it's difficult to imagine
what Dom could have done differently to
avoid it Dom begins planning for his
escape and Elena and marcos's rescue as
soon as he can secretly contacting the
shaw family to track and commandeer
Cypress flying base of operations still
he surely wishes he'd been able to
escape from Cyprus clutches earlier
during Dom's mission for Cipher in New
York Dom prevents her Lieutenant Rhodes
from killing Letty and Cipher punishes
Dom by having Elena executed Dom isn't
respond for Elena's death and he
obviously couldn't allow Letty to die
either but he'll still have to live with
the regret over essentially choosing one
of them to be killed thankfully Dom is
at least able to free himself from
Cipher in time to fulfill his promise to
Elena that he would keep their son safe
The Fast and Furious movies have often
gotten away with more than just our
resistance and instances of spectacle
from bizarre character developments to
outdated plot devices here are
questionable things on The Fast and
Furious movies that we all just ignore
Fast and Furious 6 ends with a bang by
revealing that Deckard Shore played by
Jason Statham was the one responsible
for killing Han played by Sun Kong in
Tokyo Drift with this action the
character's intimidating nature was
solidified from their sure caused all
kinds of problems for Dominic Toretto
and his surrogate family including
blowing up toretto's home by the end of
Furious 7 the gang's most ruthless
adversary had finally been defeated
seemingly putting an end to his
influence on the lead characters of Fast
and Furious except the face of the
Furious decided to go in the direction
of making him an ally to the team as he
took on a new villain Cipher played by
Charlize Theron by the film's end the
show wasn't just a helpful colleague he
ended up being the one to save toretto's
kid from the evil henchman it was
strange to see someone responsible for
murdering Han getting chummy with
toretto's family including the Fast and
Furious 6 director Justin Lin via Cinema
Blend lynched somebody asked me about
Han and Deckard Shaw I was like wait
what sure is that the barbecue in eight
really I was so confused one of the big
reasons to come back to direct F9 was I
felt like we needed to correct something
if even one of the main directors of The
Fast and Furious franchise has puzzled
by this development then maybe sure
shouldn't be a part of the family
though Brian O'Connor played by Paul
Walker returned from The Fast and the
Furious to headline 2 Fast 2 Furious
Dominic Toretto did not this meant that
square jawed law enforcement officer
needed an experienced Rebel to bounce
off of enter Roman Pierce played by
Tyrese Gibson who had a more friendly
personality than terretto from the start
and was clearly around to help maintain
the Buddy Buddy Dynamic of the first
movie but while he delivers his share of
comedic lines throughout the film PS is
not at all supposed to inhabit the
archetype of comic relief when Tokyo
Drift opted to focus on entirely new
characters both O'Connor and Pierce were
put on the back burner in fact appears
disappeared from the franchise before
finally returning nearly a decade after
his first appearance in fast 5. this
time around though Toretto and O'Connor
were firmly in the lead roles again
meaning Pierce wasn't needed to fulfill
his original job as O'Connor's new
partner but since he had to fill out a
new Niche Pierce has taken on the role
of the franchise's comic relief which
has required the character to act
drastically different friend than when
he first showed up in 2 Fast 2 Furious
while this new personality does make
Pierce's character wildly inconsistent
between his debut appearance and his
later escapades and the franchise it has
also allowed him to stick around as a
prominent fixture of The Fast and
Furious universe and for that we're
thankful
see now we talk when the Fast and the
Furious Tokyo Drift hit theaters in June
2006 it wasn't meant to be something
significant in the franchise it was an
attempt to try something new and see if
the series could extend beyond Brian
O'Connor the filmmakers certainly
weren't thinking about it factoring into
an insanely convoluted timeline in one
of the biggest action franchises ever
made as a result the use of flip phones
the car models and even the presence of
Bow Wow in the film's cast all pointed
to Tokyo Drift to being firmly set in
the year 2006. however this would get
extra complicated as the Fast and
Furious franchise eventually updid to
retcon Tokyo Drift as happening far
further in the future in 2013 Han's
death in Tokyo Drift was established as
having taken place right after the
events of Fast and Furious 6. meanwhile
Furious 7 followed up on tarato's brief
cameo in the third film by having it
revealed that he wanted to talk to Tokyo
Drift protagonist Sean Boswell about Han
suddenly a movie previously supposed to
take place in 2006 was now rooted in
2015 nearly a Whole Decade after it was
initially released trying to flip the
timeline of The Fast and Furious
Universe like this was almost audacious
enough to be admirable however it
definitely made the Mythos of a series
about Vehicles zooming by really fast
even more difficult to follow
in Fast and Furious Letty played by
Michelle Rodriguez is murdered which is
a tragic development for Dom and a
puzzling one for the franchise after all
Letty hadn't been a part of the series
since the original The Fast and the
Furious and now she was suddenly dead
however the post-credits scenes of Fast
Five shows that Letty has taken a cue
from Mark Twain in that the rumors of
her death are greatly exaggerated in the
next movie Fast and the Furious 6 Letty
is not only confirmed to be alive but
she is also shown to be working for the
movie's principal foe Owen Shaw who
apparently rescued her when she was
nearly dead oh and she's also got
amnesia which means she has no remorse
about working for sure or shooting at
her boyfriend letty's death and
Resurrection is a puzzling story term
for the series on a number of levels
particularly in the awkward way the Fast
and Furious movies refuse to give a more
detailed explanation for how exactly she
survived the fact that her Amnesia is
only sporadically referenced in Furious
7 and barely mentioned in the fate of
the Furious is also strange change
especially as it makes her heel turn in
Fast and Furious 6 feel extra and needed
audiences come to these movies for the
unbelievable there's no question about
that but going this route with handling
the death and Revival of a franchise
fixture like Letty feels one degree too
far
Elena Neves played by Elsa Pataki isn't
one of the most famous Fast and Furious
characters but she has one of the
strangest plot lines in the entire
franchise first introduced in Fast 5 as
aligned with Luke Hobbs played by Dwayne
Johnson thus making her an adversary for
the principal characters she's
eventually shown to be dating Dominic
Toretto at the start of Fast and Furious
6. her status as toretto's new love
interest isn't long for this world
though as Letty comes roaring back into
the series with this same movie
afterwards in Furious 7 Elena is shown
working alongside Lou Cobbs once again
and there are even hints that a
relationship could be forming between
the two their bond is reinforced by how
she's tasked with taking care of his
daughter all of those plot lines vanish
in the face of the Furious when Elena is
suddenly brought back to the Forefront
of the continuity as a mother of
terretto's child all her progress as a
character independent of Dom from
Furious 7 vanishes and suddenly she's a
mother of his newborn baby there are a
lot of questionable aspects about this
plot detail including how the timeline
doesn't quite add up terretto and
Elena's kids should be much older than a
newborn considering when they last were
intimate not to mention how all of this
feels totally out of character for Elena
and then her quick death caps off one of
the most bafflingly executed plot lines
in a series not short on strange
narrative detours
The Fast and Furious movies aren't
famous for their post-credit scenes but
Fast 5 features a moment worth sticking
through the credits for here Luke Hobbs
is informed by two fast two furious
character Monica Fuentes played by Ava
Mendes that Letty is Alive and Well
despite dying and Fast and Furious not
only did the sequence indicate that a
franchise staple was getting resurrected
but it indicated that Fuentes was due to
reappear in the fast Saga after
previously only appearing in the second
film Fuentes returning to this series
opened the door for Mendes to play a
more active character however Fast and
Furious 6 failed to follow up on this
tease of her returning and since then
there have been no further appearances
by Fuentes this is likely partially due
to Ava Mendes taking a self-imposed
sabbatical from acting but it's still
strange that Fast Five teed up a return
for Monica Fuentes that's yet to pay off
perhaps a prospective female-led Fast
and the Furious spin-off can finally
give Fuentes a new adventure to embark
on that's more substantive than a
post-credit sequence
prior to the release of the fate of the
Furious rumors spread that the
characters of Luke Hobbs and Deckard
Shaw were being primed for their own
spin-off movie this was set up in the
fate of the Furious which saw the duo
being incarcerated together at the same
prison in this Fantastic action sequence
they engaged in a scuffle during a
prison breakout before being forced to
work together to take down Cipher and
over the course of the story Hobbs and
Shaw did grow closer to the point that
they shared a laugh together and were
even depicted mingling at Dom's barbecue
during the film's closing scene when
stats spin-off got off the ground in the
form of Hobbs and Shore suddenly the two
were no longer buddies at the start of
the movie they were recruited by their
respective governments to save the world
and there wasn't immediate animosity
between the duo no
way I'm not working with this guy I've
been there done that rather than being
friendly they were now inhabiting a
classic buddy cop dynamic as they aimed
a slew of jokes at one another taking
shots at qualities they hated about one
another it was like they automatically
reverted to their Dynamic from the start
to the fate of the Furious without any
consideration of how the Rapport had
evolved once they left the Slumber
bobson Shore featured many stunts that
strained credulity but the awkward way
the two leads reverted to an exclusively
antagonist Dynamic was especially weird
when the Fast and the Furious set
theaters in 2001 a big takeaway for
General moviegoers was the presence of
Vin Diesel with his gravelly voice and
the believable sense of authority diesel
wasn't your average movie star so it
seemed like a no-brainer to bring him
back for the inevitable sequels however
when Too Fast Too Furious was released
diesel was nowhere to be found even his
fellow original lead Paul Walker was
back in the driver's seat it was a
puzzling move for the franchise and in
the sequel the absence is chalked up to
Toretto being on the run from the lore
in the context of the real world though
it was due to Vin Diesel both having
qualmed with the script for 2 Fast 2
Furious and having a desire to break
away from the franchise to do The
Chronicles of Riddick instead this
decision allowed diesel to follow his
own creative Pursuits but it did result
in the baffling side of seeing a fast
and furious movie not headlined by the
actor most associated with this
franchise this trait has only gotten
more puzzling as the years go by and
Diesel remains more and more of a
fixture of this Saga
Brixton law played by Idris Elba is the
most advanced adversary to ever appear
in a fast and furious movie he isn't
just ruthlessly violent he's also
outfitted with cyborg enhancements the
first explicitly sci-fi character and
the Fast and Furious Mythos isn't
someone you can take down with these so
considering the leads of Hobbs and sure
are just normal human beings you'd think
it would take a super complicated tactic
to defeat law and save the world Instead
The Duo is able to take him down simply
by learning the volleyball lesson that
punching him separately isn't working no
they have to punch him together
turn meant to be the culminating
teamwork of the two leads who can't
stand each other and predictable to boot
even for a fast and furious movie this
tactic for bringing down the body is
pretty questionable
with nine films spread out over nearly
two decades and a release order that
jumps all around their chronological
timeline it's fair with Fast and Furious
fans need a bit of a refresher on where
we wound up after each one here's the
ending of every Fast and Furious film
explained
despite functioning for most of its run
time as practically a beat for beat
Point Break remake The Fast and the
Furious notably diverges from the iconic
Surfer Thriller in its ending while the
1991 film sees protagonist Johnny Utah
released sympathetic antagonist Modi
only to certain death The Fast and the
Furious as its law enforcement hero
Brian O'Connor lets his lawskirting
Frenemy Go free he even gives him an
assist on his way out after initially
getting close to Dominic Toretto only as
a means to ferret out the details of his
high-speed Heist operation Brian
eventually comes to realize that he
genuinely cares about Dom and his crew
Dom and his sister Mia feel betrayed
when they learn Brian's true identity
and subsequently attempt to cut ties
with him however Brian chases Dom down
and a winner takes all quarter-mile race
with the implied Stakes being that if he
wins Dom will cooperate with being
arrested instead even though Dom crashes
his car and Brian wins the race Brian
opts to give Dom his own allowing him to
escape instead of arresting him the film
ends with dumb driving free in Mexico
and Brian having chosen their friendship
over his career as a police officer
following his decision to facilitate
Dom's Escape at the end of The Fast and
the Furious Brian Goes On The Run making
a living competing in underground street
races eventually Brian is arrested but
cuts a deal with the FBI to go into
cover and help bring down a drug lord in
exchange for a clean criminal record to
assist him Brian recruits to the strange
childhood friend of Roman Pierce who is
on parole and could use a similar deal
Brian and Roman take down the drug lord
with the help of U.S customs agent
Monica Fuentes leading to his arrest and
full pardons for the two ex-convex
unbeknownst to the FBI though Roman sets
aside some of the drug lords laundered
money for himself although he does turn
over the rest three once more Brian
suggests that two of them use the money
to open a garage together in Miami
although that doesn't wind up happening
the only main Fast and Furious film not
to center around Dom O'Brien Tokyo Drift
follows teenager Sean Boswell who has
sent to Tokyo to live with his dad after
destroying most of her residential
construction site in a drag race in
Arizona relocating to a different
continent doesn't do much to curb Sean's
Speedster ways and he quickly falls in
love with the Japanese street racing
scene the Japanese drivers all employ
the technique of drifting which allows
cars to maneuver around curves and
Corners using controlled skids after
initially failing a drifting Sean
eventually masses a skill with the help
of a local racer named Han unfortunately
not long after Han has taken Sean under
his wing the Yakuza come after Han for
stealing from them a high-speed chase
ensues and it appears that harness
killed the Final Act of Tokyo Drift
seeshawn challenging a Yakuza member's
nephew to a race which will determine
which of them is allowed to remain
safely in Tokyo using its Newfound
drifting skills Sean wins now
established as a drift King of Tokyo
Sean continues racing and the film
closes with an American arriving to
challenge him to a race Dominic Toretto
who claims that he used to work with Han
along with the next two films a fourth
film in the franchise actually takes
place between two fast two furious and
Tokyo Drift after Tokyo Drift ended with
the reveal that Darman Han used to work
together Fast and Furious Cuts back to
that time five years after the end of
the first film the film opens with dumb
stealing fuel tankers and a Dominican
Republic with a crew that includes Han
as well as Dom's girlfriend Letty
meanwhile after getting his criminal
record expunged at the end of 2 Fast 2
Furious Brian O'Connor is now working as
an FBI agent Tom and Brian's pass
eventually cross when Dom hears that
Letty has been killed and the search for
a killer leads him to a Mexican drug
lord that Brian is also attempting to
track down together the two team up to
apprehend the drug lord and Brian
manages to arrest him with Dom's help in
the process Dom kills one of the drug
lords henchmen whom he blames faletti's
death making Brian's attempts to clear
his name futile the film ends with dom
being sentenced to 25 years to life in
prison and able to accept this outcome
Brian resigns from the FBI and teams up
with Mia along with a couple members of
Dom's crew to break him out of prison
the film ends with Brian leading a group
of cars to Interceptor Dom's prison
burst
picking up directly on the heels of Fast
and Furious Fast Five opens with Brian
and his accomplices breaking dumb out of
prison together with Mia they flee to
Rio De Janeiro by this time Brian and
Mia have rekindled their romance from
the first film and during the course of
the film Mia makes a game-changing
revelation we have no choice but to
speak pregnant
in order to build a new life Dom and
Brian hatch a scheme to steal 100
million dollars from a major crime Lord
which requires them to recruit a crew to
help pull off the heist this includes
Han from Tokyo Drift and Roman from too
fast to Furious along with tej Giselle
Leo and Santos meanwhile Diplomatic
Security Service agent Luke Hobbs and
local Brazilian police officer Elena
Neves are in pursuit of Brian and Dom
however after the crime Lord's men
murder Hobbs team he and Elena agree to
join forces with Brian and Tom to help
with the heist in a spectacularly
destructive series of events that
involves dragging us safe through the
city behind fast-moving cars the group
is successful in stealing the money
after killing the crime Lord Hobbs
agrees to give Brian and Dahmer 24-hour
Head Start provided they leave the money
the duo agree but only because they've
already secretly swapped out the money
the real loot is divided amongst the
crew who scatter across the globe each
with a hefty pile of cash at the end of
the film Elena who are now a couple
relaxed on a beach with Brian and Mia
meanwhile unbeknownst to them Monica
Fuentes from 2 Fast 2 Furious gives Hobb
a file that shows that Letty is actually
still alive
living large following their successful
Heist at the end of Fast Five Don's crew
is eventually reunited by Luke Hobbs who
reaches out to Dom for assistance in
capturing a terrorist named Owen Shaw
working as a member of Shaw's crew is
Letty who has completely lost her
memories of her life before she
disappeared in the fourth movie
motivated by a desire to find Letty and
restore her memories Dom's crew teams up
to track down Shore although he
eventually gets away in the process Dom
saves let his life prompting her to
decide to switch sides and stay with him
the Final Act of the film sees Dom's
crew pursuing Shore to a Runway where
Dom's group is determined to keep Shaw's
plane from taking off with its weapons
of mass destruction they are successful
in stopping sure but Giselle is killed
in the process of saving Han sure is
grievously injured after being thrown
from the plane and is subsequently
arrested by Hobbs who secures pardons
for Dom and his crew as payment for
their assistance at the end of the film
although Letty still doesn't have her
memories Elena gracious steps aside to
allow her and Dom to be together
meanwhile a grieving Han decides to take
his Fast Five money to Tokyo where he
and Giselle had once talked about moving
which is what puts him there at the
beginning of Tokyo Drift in a
mid-credits scene it is revealed that
the person whose car crashed into Han in
that film was driven by Owen Shaw's
brother Deckard who is now seeking
Vengeance on the people who injured and
captured his brother
the seventh fast and furious film picks
up just before the sixth film ends
showing Deckard Shore stealing
information on Dom's crew from hobbs's
Office injuring Hobbs in the process
shortly after that sure attacks Han in
Tokyo which we previously saw both in
the middle of Tokyo Drift and at the end
of Fast and Furious 6. as short targets
the rest of Dom's crew a mysterious
government operative named Mr Nobody
offers to help Dom stop sure if Dom's
team can assist him Mr Nobody needs help
recovering a computer tracking program
called God's eye as well as its creator
a hacker named Ramsay who has been
kidnapped by terrorists after rescuing
Ramsey Dom's team manages to help Mr
Nobody stop the terrorists and subdue
Shore who is taken into custody by
Hobbes in the process Letty finally
regains her memories revealing that she
and Dom actually got married before they
parted ways in the fourth film meanwhile
Mia has announced that she's pregnant
again and Brian decides that it's
finally time for him to walk away from
its dangerous life in in order to be
with his family the film ends with the
crew bidding a bond farewell to Brian as
he drives off into the sunset and Dom
thinking back on all the happy memories
they've shared together this ending also
served as an emotional eulogy for Paul
Walker who died in an unrelated accident
to join the film's production
after regaining her memories of their
wedding the eighth Fast and Furious film
opens with Darman Letty taking their
long overdue honeymoon in Havana
unfortunately while they're there Dom is
confronted by a cyber terrorist named
Cipher who blackmails him into betraying
his crew and helping her steal weapons
the rest of Dom's crew along with Hobbes
and surprisingly Deckard Shore are
recruited by Mr Nobody to help them stop
Cipher eventually it's revealed that
Cipher has captured Elena and her
infant's son it turns out that Elena was
pregnant when she and Dom spit up and
she never told him however while Albert
Lee cooperating with Cipher dumb quietly
tries to undermine her which leads to
cypher having Elena executed ultimately
though Dom is able to get the upper hand
by helping the Shaw Brothers mother who
repays a favor by tasking her sons with
rescuing Dom's son once the shores have
recovered the baby Dom turns on Cipher
thwarting her plans to incite nuclear
war and reassuring his team that he'd
never really turned on them after all
unfortunately though Cipher manages to
Escape before she can be apprehended at
the end of the film Dom finally names
his son while Hobbes decides to walk
away from his job with a Diplomatic
Security Service for good everyone
meet Brian
following the events of the fate of the
Furious Deckard Shaw learns that his
sister Hattie has disappeared along with
a programmable supervirus and is tasked
by the CIA to team up with Hobbes in
order to find her once they locate
Hattie he was an MI6 agent they learned
that she only infected herself with the
virus in order to keep it from falling
into the hands of Brixton law a
terrorist who has been cybernetically
augmented with super strength Brixton
frames both Shore siblings along with
Hobbes as terrorists and the trio flees
to hobb's childhood home in Samoa to
figure out their next steps there they
prepare to make their stand against
brixton's organization
eteon alongside Hobbes Brothers as they
work to defeat Brixton and his soldiers
one of Pop's Brothers figures out how to
extract the virus from Hattie even if
the process is frustratingly slow after
his defeat Brixton is killed remotely by
the Unseen director of eteon who then
insinuates that they'll be coming after
Hobson Shore you don't remember
you will
it's gonna be a hell of a reunion
however Hobbs and sure are unintimidated
by etian threats the film ends with the
sure siblings breaking their mother out
of prison and Hobbes learning about the
existence of another potentially even
more dangerous supervirus
due to a combination of Savvy marketing
a powerful International draw and not
taking itself too seriously The Fast and
Furious franchise has become a veritable
money printing machine but not everyone
wants to be a part of it here are some
actors who turned down roles in the fast
Saga
Denzel Washington would have been a
massive get for the Fast and Furious
franchise the series has boasted its
fair share of Big Time actors but Denzel
is on another level not only has he been
incredibly successful at the box office
but he's also taken home two Oscars for
his roles in glory and Training Day hey
I know you got Secrets everybody got
secrets
didn't know you like to get wet though
deadline writes that Universal
approached Denzel to appear at the end
of the sixth film which would sag into
him playing the role of the main villain
in Furious 7. he apparently was not
interested however and turned down the
opportunity ultimately the role went to
Jason Statham Statham is obviously a big
star in zone right but not quite on the
same level as the two-time Oscar winner
you may be unfamiliar with the name
Deepika paducon unless you're a big fan
of Bollywood however the model actress
is hugely popular in Indian Cinema and
that makes her star in the largest film
producing industry in the world the Fast
and Furious franchise owes much of its
success to the international market so
it makes sense that they'd want to
recruit worldwide Stars into the fold
they tried to do just that with paducon
and Furious 7 but she had to turn down
the offer at the time Padukone had never
appeared in an American Film as she told
India today she had already committed to
a domestic film and didn't feel right
backing out but she also said she would
love to do a Hollywood film in the
future she got her wish just a few years
later and in a role alongside Vin Diesel
as well Padukone appeared in XXX return
of Xander cage in 2017 and has
reportedly been cast in XXX 4.
when the Fast and Furious franchise
began in 2001 Ja Rule was one of the
biggest rappers in the world he was in
the process of making the transition to
acting and appeared in a very small role
in The Fast and the Furious as a
character named Edwin who went up
against Paul Walker and Vin Diesel's
characters in a street race he did not
win
interestingly Ja Rule could have gone on
to be one of the faces of the franchise
if he'd been interested in an interview
with Grant land John Singleton the
director of Too Fast Too Furious
recalled jaw got too big for himself he
turned it down he turned down a half a
million dollars to be in the sequel
Singleton said he repeatedly tried to
get jaw rule to the table but eventually
decided to swap his character out for
one played by a different rapper
Ludacris who has since appeared in more
than half of the Fast and Furious films
apparently Ludacris wasn't the first
potential replacement for Ja Rule
originally rapper Redman was eyed to
take on the role once Ja Rule dropped
out of 2 Fast 2 Furious red man was
apparently geared up to replace him he
apparently had to drop out due to
scheduling conflicts the TV series
method in red came out around the same
time as did a few other projects instead
the role went to ludicrous just like Ja
Rule Redman's acting career has been
fairly stagnant since this role passed
him by it would have been interesting to
see how the franchise might have evolved
if either one of them had been cast
instead of ludicrous
even though the Fast and Furious
franchise has become a blockbuster
series over the years and took a few
films for it to find its footing and
figure out what it wanted to be most of
the main players have stuck with it over
the Long Haul but the core group didn't
come together overnight in fact in 2017
a producer revealed that Timothy
Oliphant was initially targeted to star
in the first film apparently when the
Fast and the Furious was originally
pitched to Universal the studio agreed
to produce the film as long as Oliphant
was cast as the lead role of Don Toretto
Oliphant turned the world down which
brought the filmmakers to their backup
Vin Diesel diesel took the reins of the
franchise and has appeared in almost
every film since the Fast and Furious
franchise sure loves its European
baddies in recent films we've seen Luke
Evans Jason Statham and Idris Elba all
show up as Central antagonists an
impressive roster that also almost
included David Tennant yes we reportedly
almost saw the one-time Doctor Who
tangling with Vin Diesel and Dwayne
Johnson so what went wrong well I don't
know I can't worry about everything
according to Latino Review tenant was in
talks with director Justin Lin about
taking on a major role in Fast and
Furious 6. we don't know which part he
was being considered for but it seems
likely that it would have been one of
these Shaw Brothers roles that
eventually went to Evans and Statham
whatever ultimately went down during
negotiations tenant wound up moving on
to other projects tenant has proven he
can do over-the-top villainy very well
his performance in Jessica Jones as the
Despicable kilgrave gave audiences one
of the best Marvel villains to date we
certainly wouldn't mind seeing him get
behind the wheel in the Fast and Furious
franchise
another rapper who was targeted for the
franchise but had to turn it down Eminem
was actually approached twice to be a
part of The Fast and Furious films both
times prior commitments kept him from
coming on board and both roles he turned
down would go on to be major parts in
the films Eminem was actually offered a
very big role in the first film he was
approached to take on the role of Brian
O'Connor which eventually went to Paul
Walker when Eminem was approached to
take the role he was currently in
development of his own film Eight Mile
and had to remain available for it just
think Eminem could have been one of the
faces of the franchise according to fuse
Eminem was later approached to do a song
for the soundtrack of furious 7. he
again turned it down due to a different
film he was already heavily involved
with the movie Southpaw and he did not
want to have multiple songs competing
with one another
Eliza Dushku was extremely in demand
when the Fast and the Furious was in
development apparently the role of Mia
Toretto was not only offered to Dushku
but was reportedly written specifically
with her in mind deshku turns the role
down for unknown reasons but she was
extremely busy at the time with both
television and film projects so it isn't
hard to imagine why many different stars
were reportedly attached after Dushku
passed Jessica Biel Kirsten Dunst Sarah
Michelle Geller Bijou Phillips and
Natalie Portman are all rumored to have
auditioned for the role before it went
to Jordana Brewster Vin Diesel returned
to the franchise fold later but he did
refuse an offer to appear in Too Fast
Too Furious and the reason is
fascinating diesel was offered 25
million dollars to star in Too Fast Too
Furious but didn't like the script or
the direction the series was headed he
viewed the first film as a classic and
said I was an idealist and to me the
script wasn't continuing the story they
were capitalizing on the brand and
milking the success of it as long as
they could of course since these
full-time return to the franchise with
the fourth installment The Fast and
Furious movies have morphed from a story
about cops out to infiltrate a street
racing gang into a wildly over-the-top
Saga fueled by globetrotting action
Espionage and an increasingly casual
relationship with the loss of nature
the ground's coming fast continuing the
story will only take you so far
this one is a bit of a cheat because as
far as we can tell Guardians of the
Galaxy Star Dave Batista has never
actually been offered a role in the
franchise that said his refusal of a fan
pitch was enough of an adamant refusal
that we had to include it once the news
broke that John Cena would be appearing
in F9 a fan tagged Batista on Twitter
with this pitch The Rock and John Cena
will get a fast and furious spin-off
also and Dave Batista will be the
villain Batista responded with two
nauseated emojis and the words thank you
for your consideration hashtag I'd
rather do good films now we love Batista
but that's a pretty bold response from a
man who has starred in not one but two
Escape Plan sequels besides those two
missteps however Batista has been fairly
choosy with most of his roles Never Say
Never but that big time dunk on Vin
Diesel's franchise will probably keep
the animal out of Fast and Furious films
for a while
a story that spans decades and even
jumps around in time is bound to have a
few plot holes that could bring the
audience's enjoyment to a screeching
halt however when it comes to the Fast
and Furious franchise those reality
busting moments might just be part of
the charm
in the oft forgotten Too Fast Too
Furious Brian O'Connor finds himself an
outlaw living in Miami and doing what he
does best street racing the person
behind the Miami underworld street
racing scene is mechanic and organizer
tej Parker when fans are first
introduced to the character he's a
humble mechanic who used to street race
like Brian however after hitting a wall
doing 120 miles per hour he doesn't
drive anymore instead he just organizes
races tej then disappears until Fast
Five when he's called to Brazil to help
Brian and Tom Toretto with a heist
that's where he also demonstrates A
Renewed ability to drive an intimate
knowledge of high-tech safes and the
ability to acquire almost anything in
the world for their odd little Safe
House in Rio by the fate of the Furious
he's also demonstrated that he's an
expert martial artist and a hacker
that's capable of impressing Ramsay who
multiple governments are seeking for her
technology tej goes from being a humble
mechanic to a world class criminal
mastermind hacker driver fighter and
Acquisitions expert at no point is the
impressive expansion of his skill set
adequately explained a brief attempt to
justify his skills was made in Fast Five
but tej simply said he had a life before
Brian met him in Too Fast Too Furious
that actually muddies the waters further
implying he had these skills back then
and chose not to use them people can get
good at things over the course of their
lives but tej is simply too good at too
many things
in Fast and Furious 6 Owen Shaw's
introduced as the man that's been using
a team similar to Dom's family to
conduct all kinds of unseemly business
around the globe furthermore he's
recruited Dom's old childhood flame
Letty taking advantage of the fact that
the attempt on her life in Fast and
Furious left her with no memory by the
end of the film Owen is responsible for
the death of Giselle a member of Dom's
crew after defeating Owen Deckard Shaw
comes out of the woodwork to get revenge
he starts by assassinating Han a
longtime member of Dominic's crew he
doesn't stop there Deckard blows up
Dominic's Los Angeles home which he
shares with his sister Brian and their
son fortunately everyone makes it out
alive Shaw later attacks Dom at Han's
funeral and makes several other attempts
on his life before being captured and
thrown in jail however one film later
Dom is backed into a corner and has no
choice but to trust his old enemies with
none other than his own baby despite
straight up murdering his close friends
stealing his girlfriend and trying to
kill his family Dom trusts the Shaw
Brothers to not betray him while they do
his Dirty Work once the mission is over
he even welcomes Deckard to a family
Barbecue in New York City forgiveness is
a very complicated thing but this is a
bit much
the first movie opens with Brian
O'Connor taking his shot at becoming a
detective by going undercover in the
street racing world the film ends with
him befriending Dominic Toretto and
letting him Escape custody just like
that he goes on the run and becomes a
full-fledged criminal and fugitive he's
eventually found by the FBI in Miami but
instead of arresting him they recruit
him to do a job for them and bust a
worse criminal he complies with the
request leading to his record Being
cleared but it doesn't stop there the
next time the audience sees Brian he's a
full-on FBI agent now someone with a
clean record can presumably go through
the steps to become an FBI agent however
given that the FBI are the ones that
cleared him in the first place it's
improbable to think that they weren't
aware of who he was or his propensity
for letting Street racer friends Escape
Justice it's almost like the feds get
what's coming to them when Fast and
Furious ends with Brian predictably
offering to let Dominic off the hook
only to have to orchestrate his daring
Prison Break Weeks Later in the end
Brian ends up on the wrong side of a
wanted poster but he frankly shouldn't
have ever been trusted on the right side
in the first place
fate of the Furious had the burden of
having to top the seven movies that came
before it its attempt to do that can be
summed up in a daring scene in which
Dominic Toretto has to face off against
his own team in a New York City chase
Dom however has the support of the
criminal mastermind Cipher who has her
team of expert hackers take over
autonomous cars in the city and remotely
drive them like they're a sea of
unfriendly metal Cipher says I want
every chip with a zero day exploit in a
two-mile radius around that motorcade
now
hack em all to put it really really
simply a zero day exploit is basically a
bit of software that hackers are able to
well hack on its own it doesn't come
anywhere close to explaining how
minivans and older model sedans could
get hacked and driven like remote
control vehicles simply puts the
impressive looking sea of cars that
Cipher has her team manifest a Dom in
stealing a nuclear football simply
cannot exist Not only would the gridlock
in New York City be too immense to get
the cars past a few miles per hour but
the scene shows her controlling cars
that the audience has led to believe
have both a cassette player and a
high-tech Auto driving chip
the big plot twist in fate of the
Furious hinges on Dominic's old lover
Elena having secretly given birth to his
baby however for those keeping track of
the timeline of events that really
doesn't add up Elena is introduced and
develops a romantic relationship with
Dominic in Fast Five when we see her
again in Fast and Furious 6 she agrees
to let Dom go so he can be with letting
now that she's alive we're sure but it's
her choice to help move on with her life
she joins Lucas Hobbs at the Diplomatic
Security Services when we see her again
in Furious 7 she's a full-fledged agent
having clearly gone through whatever
presumably lengthy process goes into
making a local Rio police officer who
ran off with a wanted International
fugitive into a DSS agent what's more
she doesn't seem to be showing a baby
bump at all when deckardshaw explodes
her and Hobbs out the window of a very
tall building fortunately that death
defying stunt had no impact on her
unborn child overall it just doesn't
really track that she would have had a
baby with dom she would have had to
conceive a child experience the events
of three movies and get a new career off
the ground in a matter of weeks she
certainly wouldn't have been able to
hide it from Hobbes who would have
likely told Dom that he's got a love
child out there it's a pretty big plot
hole for something that will seemingly
inform a lot of the franchise going
forward everyone
meet Brian
anyone who watched Fast and Furious 6
was likely struck by two things during
its climax the first being the thrilling
action and the second being the fact
that it appeared to take place on a
seemingly endless runway for those who
don't know the climactic scene sees the
bad guys trying to escape in a plane
with one of the good guys they're
hostage Dom's crew has to catch up in
their cars and somehow find a way to
ground the plane and get their friend
off before it takes off what ensues is a
roughly 13 minute action sequence that's
truly unlike anything that came before
it since the movie premiered in 2013
many internet sleuths and amateur
mathematicians have done their best to
calculate exactly how long the runway
would have to be in order to accommodate
the lengthy chase the people at vulture
factored in the car's speeds and
consulted an actual pilot to tell them
how fast a cargo plane like that needs
to go before it can take off and their
estimate put the runway at about
28.8 miles long the folks at the BBC
however factored in the idea that the
movie was cutting between multiple
things happening at once and put its
estimate at
18.37 miles long regardless they both
agree that the film's runway well
exceeds the largest paved runway in the
world which is around 3.5 miles fast and
the furious reunited the original gang
from the first movie and is in many ways
the first direct sequel to the original
The Fast and the Furious movie the thing
that brings Brian O'Connor and Dominic
Toretto back together is the sudden and
tragic death of their mutual friend
Letty when Brian convinced Letty to be
an informant to the FBI she got involved
with some bad Runners one of them
Phoenix betrayed her and chased her down
he wrecked her car and is believed to
have put a bullet in her head later in
the movie he tells Dom that he doesn't
remember letty's face he couldn't
last time I saw it it was burning so
apparently there was a fire in Fast and
Furious 6 Brian goes to prison and is
sold by Phoenix's boss that Phoenix
actually pointed his gun at the gas tank
and blew up the car first of all a
bullet to the gas tank doesn't always
blow up a car in real life but that's
not the main issue the main issue is him
saying he definitely killed Letty and
even saw her body burning as fans know
Letty was blown clear of the wreckage no
bullet wounds and definitely no Burns
instead she just has a nasty case of
Amnesia which explains why she doesn't
remember Giselle bringing her to the
hospital where she was found and
recruited by Owen Shaw
fate of the Furious begins with Lucas
Hobbs being approached by a fellow DSS
agent to inform him that he needs to
recruit toretto's team for a job
retrieving an EMP he's told in no
uncertain terms that this operation in
Berlin is off the books if he's caught
he will go to prison and be completely
disavowed by his agency Hobbs accepts
not knowing that Toretto had been
approached by Cipher and blackmailed
into betraying his team Hobbs is
arrested and sent to prison as promised
however despite committing a crime in
Berlin and being disavowed by the DSs he
finds himself in a DSS prison the same
one that's housing Deckard Shaw the
question is if the DSs wanted to disavow
Hobbes for getting pinched in Berlin why
didn't they just let police in Berlin
imprison him how did he end up in the
custody of the people that are actively
trying to pretend that they have nothing
to do with him one could argue that Mr
Nobody orchestrated the whole situation
so he could bring Shaw into the mix
however before Hobbes actually goes into
his prison cell he's approached by Mr
Nobody with an offer to work for him
which he rejects this makes the ensuing
prison riot a clear Plan B for Mr Nobody
admittedly no true fan of the franchise
would sacrifice the prison riots scene
in that movie for all the international
prisoner exchange Logistics in the world
However the fact remains that it's a big
plot hole at the conclusion of Furious 7
Letty reveals that at some point during
the movie she got the entirety of her
memory back just in time for the news to
somehow heal Dom's wounds and bring him
back to Consciousness by the eighth
movie she's back to the character we saw
last in Fast and Furious however it's
not fully explained how Letty got her
memory back or why in the world she
decided to sit on that information until
Dom was basically dead it's very subtly
implied earlier in the film that her
fight with Cara and Abu Dhabi may have
knocked something loose in her brain
sadly it's never fully explained and it
doesn't look like the remainder of the
franchise has any plans to backtrack to
address that instead odds are good
they'll Forge ahead with even more
reality bending over-the-top action
movie Insanity not that anyone's
complaining about that
the original The Fast and the Furious in
2001 each film in the franchise has
added more names onto the roster with
two decades worth of fast films and more
on the way that's a lot of faces and
backstories to remember so we've
recapped every main character story
including where they started where they
are now and any notable stops they've
made along the way
when we meet Dominic Toretto in the Fast
and the Furious he's helping his sister
Mia run their family's small La Market
while also running an operation stealing
Electronics off moving 18-wheelers and
participating in illegal street races
Dom was once incarcerated for assaulting
the man he blamed for causing the
accident that killed his father however
that wasn't enough to steer him away
from crime which eventually led to him
going on the run to avoid arrest Dom's
been with his girlfriend Letty since
they were teenagers they eventually
marry in the fourth film although their
wedding isn't revealed until the 7th in
between when Dom's forced to flee
Justice again he learns that he's been
killed after taking time to grieve he
dates Elena Nevis bothering a child with
her although he doesn't learn about his
son's existence until months after he's
born while Elaine is pregnant he learns
that he's alive but suffering from
Amnesia Elena steps aside so they can be
together eventually Letty regains her
memories and following Elena's death
lydian Dom raised the sun together whom
Dom names after his best friend everyone
meet Brian after many films spent
evading Justice Dom's taste for Crime
increases over the course of the series
although he tends to Target greedy
corporations and corrupt crime Lords but
the most valuable thing to him is family
specifically the crew he's assembled to
help him pull off his various schemes
the most important thing in life will
always be the people in this room
right here
right now in Fast and Furious 6 Dom and
his crew partner with the government to
bring down various terrorists earning
them full pardons for their past crimes
introduced in the Fast and the Furious
undercover LAPD officer Brian O'Connor
initially ingratiates himself with dom
under false pretenses his goal is to
earn Dom's trust so that he can catch
him and his crew in the act and arrest
them all but gradually his friendship
with dom turns genuine and Brian
ultimately chooses Dom over his career
Brian goes underground but is found by
the FBI who offer him a deal bring down
drug lord Carter Varone and get pardoned
Brian agrees and joins the FBI later he
sends Letty undercover with cartel
leader arturobraga but later learns
she's been killed to track down her
killer he reunites with dom as well as
Dom's sister Mia whom Brian briefly
dated years before when Dom kills
letty's supposed murderer and earns
himself a lifelong prison sentence Brian
ditches his career again to partner with
Mia and free him later when Nia tells
Brian she's pregnant Brian and Don
decide to pull off one last Heist that
will allow them to drop off the grid and
live in peace but Brian is pulled back
to crime twice more after that once when
Dom learns that letty's alive and again
when their crew is targeted by a
terrorist finally with a second baby on
the way Brian decides to step away from
the fast furious lifestyle for good
settling down with Mia and his growing
family off-screen Brian was written out
of the franchise because of Paul
Walker's sudden death during production
of furious 7. while Mia can still return
as part of the crew Brian's story is
complete with his character last seen
driving off happily into the sunset
bloody Ortiz has long been Dom's partner
in everything sticking by him even when
Dom keeps leaving her behind after he
goes on the run at the end of The Fast
and the Furious Letty spends several
years tracking him down eventually
finding him in the Dominican Republic
picking up where they left off the
couple wastes no time in secretly
marrying before pulling their biggest
Heist yet but when the plan goes
sideways Dom Goes On The Run once again
leaving Letty on her own letting Brokers
the deal with Brian she'll go undercover
to help bring down Braga in exchange for
Dom's party but when she uncovers the
plot to kill her she tries to flee only
to be left for dead eventually Letty
awakens the hospital with amnesia and is
taken in by criminal owned Shaw Letty
works for years as part of Shaw's crew
with no memory of her former life but
switches sides when she encounters Dom
and he wins her trust the two date for a
while but Letty breaks up with him
because she doesn't think they should be
together while she still lacks her
memories however she regains them when
Dom's nearly killed and the two finally
take they're long overdue honeymoon even
when Dom appears to betray the team
after being blackmailed Letty never
loses faith and welcomes him back into
the family with open arms
no I never left today I know
and you know I never will
I know
Mia Toretto resisted her brother's
criminal Endeavors for a long time but
she's eventually pulled in when Dom is
sentenced to prison and she helps Brian
break him out after that Mia sticks with
Brian as they travel internationally and
pull off during heists when they're
double-crossed by a crime Lord named
Reyes Brian and Dom believe they'll need
to split up to avoid being caught Mia
disagrees revealing she's pregnant the
trio instead decided to recruit a crew
to steal 100 million dollars of Reyes
money so that they can go underground
and live in peace once the heist is
complete Mia and Brian settle down in
the Canary Islands there she gives birth
to their son jack afterwards she agrees
that Brian should help Dom find Letty
while she stays with Jack but she gets
kidnapped by Howard's shop after being
freed just as Mia realizes She is
expecting their second child their house
blows up Brian joins Dom for one final
mission and once their family is finally
safe again Mia and Brian retire for good
however Mia will be rejoining the action
this time without Brian when her
estranged older brother Jacob shows up
in F9
Roman Pierce started stealing cars at a
young age but when his friend Brian
O'Connor joined the LAPD Roman grew
resentful especially when Brian did
nothing to help when Roman was arrested
the two reconnect In Too Fast Too
Furious when Brian recruits Roman to
help in an investigation requiring them
to go undercover in return the FBI
promises them both a parting they
complete their mission and clear their
names and recover a large amount of
stolen money unbeknownst to the FBI
though Roman also sets aside a generous
portion of the cash for himself Roman
re-enters the picture in Fast Five when
Brian and Dom need someone on their team
who can talk his way out of any
situation after pocketing 11 million
dollars from that Heist Roman lives
lavishly buying expensive cars and a
private jet but still rejoins the crew
whenever he's needed he helps Dom find
Letty and foil both Shaw Brothers and
sticks around after Brian retires when
Dom seems to betray the crew while being
blackmailed by Cipher Roman is part of
the group that works to stop him and is
quick to welcome him back once the truth
is revealed
introduced in 2 Fast 2 Furious super
mechanic tej meets Brian O'Connor while
Brian is living in Miami and the two
become friends through the street racing
machine later Tasha's sis Brian and
Roman in their undercover FBI assignment
Brian brings tej back in for the heist
and Fast Five using his Tech skills to
hack into reyes's advanced security
system tej also becomes close to Roman
although the two never miss an
opportunity to get under each other's
skin from Fast Five on tej works as an
integral part of the crew working as the
team's mechanic hacker and occasional
driver
only appearing in 2 Fast 2 Furious Suki
is a street racer with a mostly female
crew of her own she is friends with
Brian and tej and proves a valuable
asset when Roman and Brian need help
throwing the police off their set waltez
drives Brian's karsuki drives Romans
leading the police on a wild goose chase
away from their actual targets
a significant character in 2 Fast 2
Furious Monica Fuentes is an undercover
U.S customs agent who's working to
expose Miami drug lord Carter Varon when
Brian and Roman are also embedded in the
operation Monica blows her cover to pass
Brian important information realizing
Monica's betrayal Varone takes her
hostage aboard his boat but Brian and
Roman distract him long enough for
Monica to take advantage of the
situation she holds veronic gunpoint
until she's able to arrest him several
years later she alerts Hobbes but Letty
is still alive
ex-massad agents Giselle is introduced
as an employee of Arturo Braga in the
fourth film however Giselle warns Dom
that Braga plots to kill his drivers
later Dom saves giselle's life then
recruits to Giselle in Fast Five as an
official member of his crew I think I'm
in love
after becoming a couple in Fast Five
Gisele and Han are in Hong Kong together
when they receive Dom's call to come
help stop Shaw and save Letty in the
sixth film tragically toward the end of
the film giselle's hanging off the top
of the speeding car when she sees one of
Shaw's henchmen preparing to kill Han
making a split second call Giselle
releases her grip on Han's hand in order
to kill his attacker saving his life as
she falls to her death
Han got his start and director Justin
Lin's earlier film better luck tomorrow
in high school Han was part of an
organized cheating operation that spun
out of control and eventually resulted
in a murder following the events of that
film Han left to travel the world he met
Dom in Mexico and occasionally helped
with various missions Han's first
appearance is in the third film but
chronologically his first mission is in
the fourth released film in the
franchise which serves as a prequel to
The Third quiet observant and adaptable
Han helps with Dom's heists in the
fourth fifth and sixth movies during
which he also falls in love with fellow
crew members Giselle the two dream of
globetrotting and growing old together
but those plans are dashed when Giselle
sacrifices herself to save Han while
working to take down Owen Shah grieving
Han heads to Tokyo where he befriends a
group of local Street Racers and takes
American teen Sean Boswell under his
wing Han also begins stealing from the
Yakuza eventually finding himself in a
high-speed chase once his crimes are
discovered the chase ends in a horrific
but it turns out to be no accident Han
was targeted by Owen's brother Deckard
Shaw it appears Han dies in the crash
but F9 reveals that somehow Han actually
survived and will rejoin Dom's crew
the youngest protagonist in the
franchise Sean Boswell appears in the
Fast and the Furious Tokyo Drift as an
Alabama teen with a penchant for
reckless driving after being sent to
Tokyo to live with his father Sean
quickly Falls in with the city street
racing scene but the Japanese Racers all
know how to drift maneuvering around
Tech Corners via controlled skids a
skill which Sean is initially unable to
master Han takes Sean under his wing and
teaches him how to drift Sean also
flirts with a girl that turns out to be
the girlfriend of Takashi the local
drift king and the nephew of the Yakuza
member after Hans apparently killed
while being pursued by the Yakuza Sean
challenges Takashi to a race with the
loser agreeing to leave Tokyo for good
thanks to Han's teaching Sean beats
Takashi and is crowned the new drift
King afterward he meets Dom while Dom is
in Tokyo investigating Han's death
an American Army brats Twinkie
eventually landed in Tokyo selling
stolen goods out of Han's garage he met
Sean Boswell in high school and they
become friends after they bond over
twinkie's unique car through Twinkie
Sean is introduced to Han and the Tokyo
street racing crowd and when Sean finds
himself on the wrong side of the Yakuza
after Han's death Twinkie even gives him
money to pay off his debts the two
remain friends at the end of the movie
with Twinkie serving as the second in
command to the new drift King
originally serving as a secondary
antagonist in Fast Five Luke Hobbs
enters the picture as a Diplomatic
Security Service agent tasked with
tracking down the crew however after
finally getting the upper hand and
arresting Dom Brian and several members
of their crew hobbs's Caravan is
ambushed when Dom Brian and their friend
Vince save hobbs's life he decides to
join them to get revenge after the
mission is complete Hobbes returns to
the DSs where he learns Letty Ortiz is
alive Hobbs passes the sintel to Dom and
after Dom's crew assists in tracking
Letty down and capturing Owen Shaw Hobbs
is able to negotiate pardons for
everyone Hobbs is later injured when
Deckard Shaw breaks into the DSS in
search of information on the crew but
still helps bring Shaw to Justice later
when Hobbes is tasked with an off the
books Mission he calls on Dom and his
crew to help him but Dom's double cross
for Cipher winds up sending hops to
prison he breaks out and helps the team
stop Cipher later Hobbs is tasked by the
CIA with teaming up with Deckard Shaw to
recover a dangerous bio weapon which
leads to him reconnecting with his
estranged family in Samoa
we meet Elena in Fast Five when she is
recruited by hubs to assist in his
investigation but when she comes face to
face with dom she opts not to shoot him
when she has the chance in turn Dom's
saves her from Reyes men making Elena
question whether he could really be
guilty of crimes he's accused of after
Dom and Brian saved her life again Elena
leaves her law enforcement career to go
on the run with dom the two begin a
relationship on the Canary Islands where
she also grows close to Brian and Mia
but when Dom learns that he's alive
Elena urges him to find her Elena stays
behind to protect Mia and baby Jack
getting Jack to safety when Mia is
kidnapped after Dom finds Letty Elena
steps aside not revealing she's pregnant
with Dom's child eventually after
joining the DSs with Hobbes Elena gives
birth in secret shortly after she and
her infant son are kidnapped by Cipher
to use his leverage against Dom Elena
tells Dom she's given the baby a middle
name Marcos but she wanted Dom to choose
his first name Elena is soon executed by
Cipher as punishment for Doms and
subordination
we meet Vince in the Fast and the
Furious as a loyal member of Dom's crew
who instantly just trusts Brian part of
Vince's issue with Brian is Mia's
attraction to him since Vince wants her
attention for himself when the crew's
Heist goes drastically wrong at the end
of the first film Vince is seriously
injured prompting Brian to blow his
cover to get Vince medical attention at
some point after his recovery Vince Goes
On The Run winding up in Rio de Janeiro
where he meets the woman who'd
eventually become his wife and mother of
his son after spending years resenting
Brian Vince ultimately forgives him when
he returns in past five he offers
shelter to Brian and Mia and rejoins the
crew tragically he's killed by raised as
men when they attack hops so Dom gives
Vince's portion of the 100 million
dollar Heist to Vince's wife and son
Owen Shaw turned mercenary after being
dishonorably discharged from the
military he became an associate of
Arturo Braga which is how he met Letty
Ortiz intending to finish her off after
braga's initial attempt to kill her
failed but instead he recruited Letty as
part of his criminal crew after braga's
arrest Shah begins stealing components
to build an advanced weapon of mass
destruction which he intends to sell off
to the highest bidder he acts ruthlessly
willingly sacrificing members of his
crew and kidnapping Mia to use his
leverage to secure his freedom he's
ultimately stopped by Dom and is
grievously injured in the process after
being hospitalized for an extended
period of time Owen is transferred to a
secret location while being blackmailed
by Cipher Dawn makes a deal with Shaw's
mother to find him in exchange for her
family's assistance to which she agrees
Owen then is instrumental in helping
rescue Dom's baby from Cipher
introduced in Fast and Furious 6 as a
DSS agent and Associate of blue Cubs
Riley Hicks is an ex-soldier with an
impressive record she works alongside
Hobbes to track down Owen Shaw and his
team and is helpful in both combat and
extracting information from informants
however after Dom's group helps Hobbes
arrest Shaw Riley reveals she's been a
double agent the whole time and is
romantically involved with Shaw from
that point on Riley is openly a part of
Shaw's crew and proves willing to kill
for him in Cold Blood Riley is
ultimately killed by Letty when Letty
shoots her with a Harpoon Gun causing
her to fall from Shaw's plane to her
death
although Brian and Dom spent most of
Fast and Furious working for the drug
lord known as Braga it turns out the man
they thought was Braga was actually a
decoy the real Braga was the second in
command who'd gone by the name Roman
Campos those closest to him knew about
the deception but everyone else bought
into the LIE helping the real cartel
leader avoid detection for a while this
helps him fly under Brian and Dom's
radar however they're eventually able to
apprehend him in Mexico and he's
sentenced to life in prison at some
point prior to this though he's formed
an alliance with Owen Shaw who helped
influence braga's operation and whom
Braga hired to kill Letty while Braga is
in prison Brian poses as a prisoner to
get close to him in order to find out
more information about what happened to
Letty Braga tells him everything before
attempting to kill him but Brian manages
to get the upper hand stabbing Braga in
the leg in the process
Leo and Santos are friends of Dom's from
his time in the Dominican Republic the
pair are instrumental in helping Dom
plan and execute the fuel Heist at the
beginning of the fourth film and
reappear at the end of the film tell
Brian and Mia break Dom out of prison
after receiving their cut of their
multi-million dollar score at the end of
Fast Five Santos and Leo head to a
casino where they wager all their money
playing roulette we never learn who wins
or loses but they show up again later in
the fate of the Furious as part of Dom's
plan to fake deckard's death proving
they still have Dom's trust introduced
in the fourth film FBI agent Michael
staziak initially gets along with Brian
but the two butt heads when stasiak
brings Mia in for questioning after
Brian tricks him into letting her go
stasiak is suspicious of Brian's
loyalties he winds up second guessing
him at a critical juncture that puts
their undercover operation at risk
however stasiak still has a good enough
impression of Brian to help him sneak
back into the US in Fast and Furious 6.
he then gives Brian an alias and embeds
him in the prison where brag is being
kept so Brian can question him
first introduced in Furious 7 Ramses an
accomplished hacker who catches the
crew's attention after she invents a
device called the God's eye which can be
used to track down anyone on the planet
realizing how dangerous the God's eye
can be Ramsay sends it to a friend to
keep safe but she's then kidnapped by a
mercenary seeking the device knowing
Deckard Shaw has targeted Dom's crew the
government strikes a bargain if Dom
retrieves Ramsay and the God's eye he
can use it to track down Shaw after the
crew rescues Ramsay she helps them track
down the God's eye and defeat Shaw she
eventually joins Dom's crew permanently
Owen's brother Deckard first appears
that the end of Fast and Furious 6
tracking down and presumably killing Han
in Tokyo a former clandestine military
operative and MI6 agent turned mercenary
Deckard uses his skills to break into
the DSs offices and steal information on
Dom's team while he's in Tokyo he also
mails a bomb to Dom's childhood home
where Mia and Brian are living and
detonates it while on the phone with dom
Deckard continues his attempts to hunt
and kill the crew but he's ultimately
thwarted by Dom and taken into CIA
custody Hobbs is later put into the cell
opposite him and the two waste no time
in annoying each other but before long
the pair escaped during a prison riot
initiated by Mr Nobody a covert
government agent reluctantly Deckard
agrees to work with Dom's crew to stop
Cipher since he also blames her for
Owen's fate after helping them track
down Dom and Cipher it appears Deckard
is killed by Dom but that's revealed to
be a ruse facilitated by his mother with
Owen Deckard breaks into Cipher's plan
and rescues Dom's son whom he returns
safely to dog later deckards recruited
by the CIA to assist Hawks to their
Mutual irritation in recovering a
bioweapon possessed by deckard's Sister
Hattie
although Cipher isn't introduced until
the fate of the Furious she's been
pulling strings behind the scenes for
quite some time she's hired Owen shots
steal the components he was assembling
in Fast and Furious 6 and was The
Mastermind behind the plan to steal the
God's eye in Furious 7. it's even
implied she has ties to Braga in the
eighth movie Cipher kidnaps Elena and
her son to use his leverage to
manipulate Dom which works for a while
however while Cipher knows that Dom's
loyalty lies with his family she
underestimates how far he'll goats keep
them safe enabling him to eventually
Break Free of her control motivated by
power Cipher's goal is to start a
nuclear war even though her plans are
thwarted by the end of the eighth movie
She manages to escape and will be
returning to collectoral revenge in F9
No One Knows Mr nobody's real name or
even which government organization he
works for all we know is that he's a
covert agent who shows up in Furious 7
offering Dom the chance to track down
Deckard Shaw in exchange for his
assistance describing himself as a
shadow Mr Nobody has abundant resources
and Technology at his disposal and is
untethered by official policies and
procedures Mr Nobody shows up again in
the fate of the Furious staging a prison
riot to free Hobbs and Shaw so that they
can help Dom's crew track down their
leader meanwhile little nobody shows up
as Mr nobody's Protege in the fate of
the Furious so then who is he him he's
nothing he's like less than me
while not on the level of most of Dom's
crew little nobody still participates in
the high-speed effort to stop Cipher
from launching a nuclear submarine
we first met Shaw family matriarch
Magdalene in the fate of the Furious
when Dom sneaks away from Cipher long
enough to ask her for help Dom offers
Queenie a deal in exchange for her help
rescuing his infant son he will give her
the location of her incarcerated son
Owen the trade is acceptable to
Magdalene who like Dom values family
Above All Else sometime later Queenie
goes to prison although we never learn
why but at the end of Hobson Shaw it's
implied that she is getting ready to
break herself out thanks to a nail file
hidden in a cake delivered to her by
Deckard and Hattie
we don't know much about Jacob who will
debut in F9 but what we do know
indicates he'll be very different from
the other Toretto siblings Dom and Mia
have never mentioned Jacob and maybe
there's a good reason for that the ninth
Fast and the Furious film will see Jacob
teaming with Cipher to take down his big
brother which may prove to be the
biggest challenge Dom has ever faced
Jacob is a skilled assassin and of
course an excellent Precision driver
we'll learn what happened to set the
Toretto siblings at one another's
throats when F9 finally speeds into
theaters
foreign
[Music]